decenas de personas se agolparon a las
afueras del aeropuerto eldorado
desafiando el virus en bogotá pertenecen
a los sectores de la aviación el turismo
y la hotelería que desde el comienzo del
confinamiento del 25 de marzo quedaron
totalmente paralizados exigen una
reapertura económica total en uno de los
países con la cuarentena más larga del
mundo el desempleo es su principal
argumento ya que la desocupación escaló
al 19.8 por ciento en junio la economía
cayó un 15.7 por ciento en el segundo
trimestre del año y los sectores de la
comida el transporte el comercio y el
alojamiento vieron una caída del 34
punto 3% pero la alcaldesa de la capital
anunció una estrategia para reabrir
restaurantes aunque los demás sectores
siguen en suspenso en medio de un
incremento en las muertes en bolivia la
situación no es distinta el gobierno
lanzó una estrategia de testeo masivo
para cobijar al 43 por ciento del área
metropolitana de la paz para hacer
frente a la escalada de contagios
en 1800 personas en 600 brigadas se
espera llegar a 180 mil 180.000 familias
el gobierno argentino entretanto declaró
la televisión el internet y la telefonía
celular como servicios públicos
esenciales y decidió congelar sus
tarifas hasta el 31 de diciembre ante
las restricciones que la pandemia nos
impone nadie deberá resignar parte de
sus ingresos en afrontar aumentos en los
precios de estos servicios además
anunció que iniciará ensayos clínicos de
la vacuna china pero antes había
informado que será el distribuidor junto
a mexico de la prometedora vacuna de
oxford